Also, the health world is saying you should use talo as your fat instead of seed oils,
but would this be harmful for someone who has had breast cancer because it involves animal proteins?
No, I would not say it's harmful. There's more and more information coming out of the inflammatory
effects of seed oils, and you could say that systemic inflammation is at least a piece of all cancers,
it's a piece of all diseases, probably. And you could make a valid argument that when our society
in general was using lard and talo as their fat source in society, there were no seed oils,
so we're only using butter and talo and lard in cooking. There really was no cancer. There was
very little heart disease, but heart disease and cancer, the two number one killers of the people
in the Western world has skyrocketed since the use of seed oils. Now, you could argue that,
oh, well, there's other things that are involved with that. Yes, I would agree, toxic levels, etc.
However, I think that using talo, which is the beef equivalent of lard, lard is made from pork fat,
talo is made from beef fat, would be much healthier for you in cooking than using seed oils.